my name is andres pelorot and i'm
presenting the paper maximizing revenue
in the presence of intermediaries this
is a joint work with dragon agarwal
shibra varwakar and guru guru ganesh
we're part of the market algorithm teams
at google research
a common feature that we observe when we
think about auction design is that most
of the time we assume that the buyers
interested in getting the goods that are
sold in the auction are the one actually
bidding in the auction however in many
markets this is not actually the case
there are intermediaries who are the one
representing buyers and those
intermediaries are the one bidding in
the auction
for example in that auction world an
advertiser who wants to purchase
an impression from the publisher
is actually represented by a chain of
intermediation the ad agency and also
the dsp the demands on demand side
platform
who are the ones bidding on behalf of
the advertiser in that exchange
so what could change in auction design
when those other those intermediaries
are the one are the one building the
auction
consider the following example there are
three buyers these little mouses who
wants to purchase these cheats that is
sold by the seller through to make
analysis simpler a truthful auction a
second price auction
since these are the scenes the auction
is truthful everyone reports the value
and therefore the high valuation buyer
the mouse in the left hand side will get
the item and is going to pay the sale on
high speed
0.8
thus the revenue of the seller in this
case without intermediaries is 0.8
now because you're the intermediary this
little car which is representing the
buyer
of the left hand side the high
publishing buyer the engineering says
it's gonna charge a markup fee of 0.3
dollars as a broker whenever he
purchased a cheese only half of the
biofuel represents
so given the situation the maximum bid
that the high evolution buyer could
actually beat in the auction is no more
than 0.7 since the buyer needs to pay at
least 0.3 dollars as in the markup fee
to the intermediary
because of that the 0.8 bit of the
second highest valuation buyer is going
to win the auction and therefore 0.7 is
going to be the second highest bid which
is also the seller's revenue
so we see from this exercise that
because there is an intermediary who is
charging a markup fee
the sales revenue decreases and there is
a and if there is some optimal
allocation of the good
now consider the following example in
which now not only the high evolution
buyer is represented by intermediary but
also the second highest version buyer is
also represented by the same
intermediary
in this case the intermediary is going
to be only is going to submit only one
bit to the final auction since there's
only one item there
and therefore the second highest bid
auction is going to be the third highest
third highest valuation buyer 0.4
last the the 0.7 bit of the high
volation buyer is going to win the
action but it's going to be end up
paying 0.4
in the auction so therefore the seller's
revenue now decrease even more to 0.4
so what happened here so we see is that
because the intermediary is representing
multiple buyers he enables those buyers
to collude to decrease the price
pressure in the final auction
now to see this this example to an even
more extreme case
let's assume let's consider the case
where all three buyers are represented
by intermediary
in this extreme situation there's no
competition in the final auction as the
is going to assume only one bit
so in this extreme case the service
revenue because it's going to be zero
it's gonna sell the cheese by
a very tiny amount of price
so what we see from this example is that
we think about auction design it's very
important to take into account whether
they're in terminators in the in the
auction or not
so the pro the previous example showed
that injuries are negatively impacting
service revenue it is always the case
and the answer is no to see the to see
the to see this consider the following
example where now their dessert owns
multiple goods
two cheeses and they are the same buyers
each buyer wants to buy only one cheese
so we remain we stick with the same
exercise of thinking about truthful
auctions in this case the
vct auction is going to be third price
auction
thus each item is going to be sold by
the third highest speed and since the
auction is true so it's going to be 0.5
which means that each is sold at 0.5 to
the two highest valuation buyers and the
total revenue is one
so now what happened when there is there
is an intermediary
well if there is an intermediary and the
seller is aware about the intermediation
he may want to choose a bundling price
to set the two goods together at the
price of 2.8
since the two highest pollution buyers
the sum of the of their value is 3.5
and the market price to buy the two
goods they will have to pay 0.6 in total
and the prevalent price 2.8 the total
value which is 3.73 3.5 versus the value
of the money 2.8 and intimidation 0.6
makes that is worth to make the
transaction and therefore the engineer
will purchase the goods on behalf of
these two buyers
thus the total revenue in this situation
was 2.8 because there is an intermediary
when the previous case 1.0
so what happens here is that because the
buyer the intimidator is representing
multiple buyers the seller can start
using strategies of bundling which are
known to be profitable and and very
useful when we're thinking about
multiple goods that those strategies
would not be able to be used in the case
of
without in the case that there is no
intermediaries in the auction
so this may like it's the thing that is
always it will be a good strategy for
the buy for the seller to set the
bundling price
suppose he actually believes that the
market is as we described where one in
germany represents multiple all the
buyers and sets this bundling price
but he was wrong
and actually there's no intermediary in
the auction
oh in this in this case he's gonna be
forcing the the each buyer to buy two
goods although they care only about one
at a very high price
in particular given the valuations that
we observed in the example no no no
buyer will be able to purchase the goods
that's the revenue of the sorry the of
the service zero
since since he was since he doesn't sell
any of the goods
what we think we see from this example
is that
when we think about auction science and
engineers we also have to be careful
about the implications if the demand
structure changes
and therefore it will be important to
have an auction an auction system which
is going to be robust to the demand
structure
in this motivation let me present you
the main model that we study in this
paper
we're going to firstly assume that the
seller owns k identical items and later
discuss an extension with when we
discuss ether genius items
there are going to be n unit demand
buyers with us valuations iid run from
the cd distribution f
the introduction intermediaries are
going to be summarized by what we call
the demand structure m pi where m are
the number of intermediaries i pi l
represents the bias that intermediate
intermediate l is representing the
auction
for instance in the galaxy example of
competition this would represent that
each intermediary is the buyer and
therefore he only represents herself
also another classical canonical
instance that have been studied is the
case where one the one intermediary
represents all the buyers then one of
sony case
in that situation there's gonna be only
one intermediary with who's gonna be
representing all the buyers
so the key challenge that we want to
also discuss in this paper and we
elaborate is about how to summarize all
the interactions and decisions that
happen downstream market between the
buyers and engineers and this is going
to be summarized by the utility function
ul
of the intermediary
so we have two main interactions that we
have in mind
the first one is the surplus sharing
intermediary in this situation the
intermediary wants to maximize the sum
of the utility
of the buyers he or she represents
and the second in the second instance
that has been widely studied is the case
where engineering actually wants to
maximize its own profit
and therefore he outside as a profit
maximizer broker
so without the with these two canonical
examples we want to develop an abstract
unity function that would include as
particular instances these two cases
so at the end we're going to be assuming
that the our utility function will have
three main properties it's going to
satisfy the individual rationality that
means that intimately this if an
intermediary does not receive an item
he gets a payoff of zero
the second property that we're going to
impose is that intermediary does not
create value given the tv function which
means that the theory function of the
wire cannot be greater or any allocation
to the value he could generate through
via the the other buyers he or she
represents
and the third property which is a bit
more subtle there's more nuances is the
following which we call buyer disconnect
disconnectability
assume that the seller sets
all the prices for all the items at the
price of r
so
in a if they will not be intimidating
anybody with value greater than r will
actually try to purchase the item
in the with intermediation that could
not cannot be necessarily the case but
we're going to assume that it will
happen at least with probability tau l
the idea behind that is that towel
captures the double the level of
marginalization for instance in the case
of surplus sharing intermediary since
the intermediary wants to maximize the
value of the buyers he will always want
to purchase if a buyer wants to purchase
thus how well is one
however in the case of double
marginalization when the intermediate
profit maximizers he will start setting
markup phase and therefore with as we
saw in the previous examples there are
some times where a a buyer would like to
purchase the god
but given the fee it is not going to be
worth for him
so therefore
the probability of trade would not be
one however when distributions have nice
properties for instance has a monotone
hazard rate this probability cannot be
so small in particular for a mature
distribution
tau is actually equals to one over e
so what is our so with that in mind
what's our goal we want a goal we want
to design an auction so that the seller
maximizes his revenue
so the they
so we have a canonical similar result by
cai etal who shows that if we give you
as granted the demand structure and the
intermediaries
there is an algorithm which can
which can tell us what is the optimal
revenue that the seller should implement
the ultimate revenue mechanism that the
seller should implement to maximize the
revenue
however most of the cases this mechanism
is actually quite complex and
furthermore and this and this is
critical for our purposes is very
sensitive to the demand structure
and also the intermediary functions
meaning the downstream interaction that
happens between the engineers and the
buyers
so with that in mind
what we're going to be deci our goal of
this paper is to design
a simple mechanism but with a good
guarantees for all kind of
intermediaries
and for all demand structures that may
arise downstream market
so to have good revenue guarantees a key
technical aspect that way a key
element that we develop in the paper is
to provide a good benchmark to compare
revenue and our benchmark corresponds to
the welfare
this is corresponds to the highest
valuation the seller could have under
any demand structure which is just to
charge the highest valuation to the k
highest bidders okay highest buyers that
are that are below a that are
present in the market
the the nice property of the welfare as
a benchmark is that this this is
independent of the demand structure and
of course by definition its revenue for
any demand structure cannot be greater
than the welfare
so our goal would be to find a mechanism
such that for any demand structures any
payoff that the each emitters could have
given the property that we previously
described
would satisfy that it would have a
constant factor compared to the welfare
and because of that it will mean that it
will have a constant factor to the
optimal revenue had the hud will have
implemented the revenue maximizing
mechanism
given the demand structures and the
particular utility functions of the of
the intermediaries
so
the first the first the first point that
we realized in this one is that we
cannot assume that the distribution f is
too general
for instance if we think about the
equilibrium distribution
which has nice properties in in the
sense that it is regular according to
the majority sense that is that this
virtual evaluation phi f is not
decreasing
is such that the welfare is infinity
while the revenue is 1.
so therefore we cannot use input in this
case for instance welfare is a benchmark
because it's too it's too it's too high
to compete with that
so what we do is to restrict a bit the
class of distribution to what we call
the lambda regular distributions so
lambda regular has a
takes the virtual evaluation from
myerson and adds a lambda factor to the
first element
we're going to impose a stronger
monotonicity that is that lambda b
has minus the the inverse of the hazard
has to be increasing
but this is a subset of regular
distributions
and the nice properties of lambda
regular is that where in the paper we
showed that is close under maximum that
is that
if the distribution f is lambda regular
the maximum of
f
of n of distributions is also lambda
regular
and also
that the probability that the value is
overseas its expected value is a
constant factor that depends on lambda
and this term 1 minus lambda over 1 over
lambda is going to appear in our in our
analysis quite often so we summarized by
the c lambda
and our second result we show
is that
is that the previous tau
for the profit maximizer beta the
probability of trade that we show that
we saw that for immature is one over e
actually can be generalized for lambda
regular and the probability of trade
even he does markup fees to maximize
revenue as an intermediary to maximize
profit as an intermediary the
probability cannot be cannot be smaller
than this value c lambda
so without this assumption distribution
let me present you our our main
mechanism which is the intermediate
proof mechanism
and that is the following
let's divide in k groups buyers so
they're gonna be s buyer in each of the
groups
and we're gonna pick the highest of
those buyers compute the expected value
and charge that as the price
and we're gonna sell this we're gonna
sell each item at that price
and the mechanism is such that if there
is excess demand meaning more more more
engineers want to buy the goods than the
amount of goods we're going to be
randomly allocated among among the
interested bidders
so what's our main result is that we
showed that if the distribution is
number regular
for any demand structure
and any pages satisfying by this
connectivity with factor tau
we're gonna have that the revenue that
we're gonna obtain with this ip
mechanism this intermediate approved
mechanism is a constant factor of the
welfare
and the constant factor
it can be can be breakdown as follows
so the first element tau
comes because
the the the rents that intermediate may
be extracting
and therefore it decreased rate
the second factors c lambda
comes because of the gap between the
optimal revenue and the welfare even in
single in the single bidder's case this
is the lambdas in terms terms what's the
probability as we saw before
that the highest valuation buyer in each
of those groups are going to oversee the
expected value that we are setting as a
price
they won't have a value that appears
here is comes from some technical
assumption a technical analysis for the
case where the groups are actually the
division and divided by k is not an
integer and the last term in the
constant factor approximation is the
loss from or another statistic lemma we
show in the paper the lemma shows that
the price we set
for each items is actually comparable to
the welfare
but it has a second interpretation
it says that it will restrict a seller
to allocate each of the k goods to a by
the bucket of size and divided by k
the welfare of this alloy of this
restrictive allocation is comparable
with this constant factor to the welfare
it will not be constrained and he can
allocate freely the k goods to the end
buyers
so with this intuition in mind that's
the last element of the constant factor
that degree that we use
to compare to welfare
now let me show you
the our extension when we discuss now
the setting with heterogeneous items
so we're gonna be considering that each
item has a weight at the eye this is a
common assumption especially in display
advertisement when there are multiple
slots in the auction
so buyer's i value for the item is going
to be separable it's going to be on his
private valuation times the weight that
the good j has attached
thus in this case the welfare
the maximum revenue the seller could
possibly have under any potential
allocation is gonna be
allocating the highest good to the high
valuation buyer the second highest good
to the second highest valuation buyer
and so on
so
well even though this this a mechanism
problem
once we know the demand structure and
the intermediaries utility function is
known by itself by tayatol as the
previous as the previous example with
the homogeneous setting
it is it's hard it is unknown to find a
mechanism which have these properties to
be robust to the demand structure
so here we also show that we provide an
intermediary improved mechanism we will
start which will satisfy this robust
properties and the mechanism is as
follows we're gonna say we're gonna sell
an item at the price rj which is given
by this recursion
and the idea of this recursion has a
flavor close to the gsp and the pricing
are set so that if we are able to sell
each good at those prices we're gonna be
competitive with against welfare
so the question is what's the
probability that we're gonna be solving
each good so we show actually that if
each writer's valuation is between an
interval of u j and j minus one where u
j is given as you can see in the slide
then we know for sure that if the values
in this particular interval
the buyer i wants to purchase our item j
so the question is what's the
probability that buyer's valuation is
going to be in that interval and what's
the probability that we're going to have
k values in each of those intervals at
least to have a constant factor
approximation meaning that we have with
constant probability
trait in each of the items
so to tackle that the that key issue
we discussed in the we will discuss in
the paper we discussed in the paper a
new technique using a convex program and
duality techniques and we're able to
show that with constant probability
the items are going to be allocated each
of the edges are going to be allocated
to the first buyer the highest item and
so on
so what's the mechanism with this
pricing the mechanism is going to be as
follows so we're going to be offering to
each intermediary
a menu of all the goods
then the intermediate can purchase any
of the goods then we're going to pick
the second intermediary which is going
to be randomly chosen
and offering the remaining goods until
we go to until the end of the until the
last intermediary
so using these convex programs with
concept priority all the goods are going
to be sold
and this actually turns into this one
minus exponential that depends on lambda
expression
and therefore going to be a constant
factor of the welfare for any demand
structure for any utility function that
therefore referring it for any demand
structure of any distribution that is
lambda regular
so long as
the intermediaries are suppose sharing
intermediaries it remains unopened the
question if for the case for
interviewers for instance are profit
maximizers
so let me with that in mind
finish the stock with open questions
that are remaining
unanswered in this work
first a key assumption that we do is to
restrict to lambda regular distributions
and we as we show that
if we think about regular distributions
our technique that comparing to welfare
can no longer apply
and for the moral actually we show that
for regular distribution a uniform
singularity and pricing mechanism
even for homogeneous case as we said
worked for long regular does not work in
this general setting for regular
distributions
so there is an open question whether
exists a demand a a in a robust
mechanism robust engineer is troublesome
demand structure
and if that exists it would have to be
more complex
and the second question that we don't
discuss in the paper and we think as an
interesting venue for future research is
about extending our analysis beyond the
iid framework
what happened about intermediary
approved mechanism where buyers do not
have the same valuations and therefore
we believe that it would require some
personalized pricing in order to obtain
good revenue guarantees among all
different demand structures
thanks so much for for listening to our
for listening to my talk and look
forward to see you in the conference
thanks so much